>> SIR, YOUR APPROVAL NUMBERS
HAVE NEVER BEEN LOWER.
THIS MIGHT BE THE BEST CHANCE OF
TURNING THINGS AROUND.
THE BIG QUESTION IS CAN YOU
PERSUADE PEOPLE WHO NEVER LIKED
YOU IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> I WOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT ANY OF
THAT?
I NEED A MIKE AND AN AUDIENCE
AND I'M GOOD TO GO.
THEY ALL LOVE DARIUS TRUMP.
>> FROM THE PRODUCERS OF EMPIRE,
IT'S THEM TRUMPS.
THE FIRST SHOW TO ASK THE
QUESTION, WHAT IF DONALD TRUMP
WAS BLACK?
DARIUS TRUMP.
HIS WIFE, MALIKA.
DARIUS, JR. AND L' EVANKA.
TOGETHER, THEY ARE THEM TRUMPS.
>> DAMN.
YOU THINK THE STATE OF THE UNION
SPEECH IS GOING TO SET THE
HATERS STREET?
>> LET'S GET TO THE CAPITOL SO I
CAN DO WHAT I DO.
>> WHAT ARE ABOUT THE NEW
ALLEGATIONS.
THE TAXPAYER FUNDED GOLF
VACATIONS WITH PUFF DADDY AND
ALL THE LAWSUITS OUT OF PERM
ACADEMY?
>> NOBODY NEED TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN ME AND
RUSSIA IS BETWEEN ME AND RUSSIA.
THAT DON'T CONCERN THEM.
>> WATCH YOURSELF, MUELLER IS
CLOSING IN AND YOUR HOUSE OF
CARDS IS CRASHING DOWN.
>> I KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
MUELLER.
I KEEP THE WHITE BOYS ON A
LEASH.
>> WE ARE GETTING PULLED OVER.
>> I KNEW THAT WAS COMING.
>> ON THE NEXT THEM TRUMS --
>> LICENSE PLEASE, SIR.
>> MAN, I'M NOT EVEN DRIVING.
>> I'M NOT ASKING AGAIN.
LICENSE, NOW.
>> BE COOL, DAD.
>> WE DON'T NEED YOU LOCKED UP.
>> AIN'T NOBODY GETTING LOCKED
UP.
I'M THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT EVEN THOUGH I'M A BLACK
MAN.
>> SOMEBODY RECORD IT FOR WORLD
STOP.